so let's bring in somebody who's going
to be asking those questions today
the senator from wisconsin senator ron
johnson member of the senate foreign
relations committee
senator
what did you
learn gleaned from yesterday when they
had just three minutes to question the
diplomat
what did you learn yesterday that's
going to help you today
uh good morning brian not a whole lot i
mean obviously we learned that the
buying administration is going to
continue to blame the previous
administration for decisions that they
made you know what i find so
disingenuous about you know that blame
game is that
president biden had no problem
overturning for example successful
policies
on the border which had our border
moving towards pretty good security
he had no problem dismantling all those
successful policies but this is just the
one that he just had to abide by it's
it's completely bs
and it's dangerous for this country
you've had so much experience obviously
being a senator have you ever seen a
worse decision from a president
no
but this is just on top of other bad
decisions again this administration has
been a rolling series of disasters first
the dismantling of the successful border
policy so now we have a completely open
border more than 6 000 people being
apprehended per day for the last four or
five months that doesn't even count the
known god ways at least six hundred
thousand people be dispersed around this
country to that open border that's
population greater than the state of
wyoming so that's disaster number one
what about all the out of control
spending the incredible increase in our
debt and now you've got the withdrawal
the the surrender the the humiliating
surrender in afghanistan it's it's just
unbelievable but now they're going to
ask for 6.4 billion dollars to resettle
afghans when they freely admit that most
of the sivs are still in the country so
who did we get we're supposed to make
room for 95 000 people who are they
we don't know and of course that's
what's most troubling is because we
we're hearing from people on the ground
during the evascration that they don't
want to come forward because they they
value their jobs and they know they'll
be retaliated uh by against by this
administration so what we were hearing
was completely different than what this
administration was telling us this
administration was saying that they had
planned for every contingency that this
was organized
there were tens of thousands of uh
afghanis that just flooded the airport
nobody knows who they are we just put
them on planes we played the numbers
game
so many of these people didn't even have
any form of id whatsoever i was at fort
mccoy i asked the commanding general
when did you first hear that this was
going to be your mission he said ten
days ago i asked them could they could
they say that every afghanistan that
they had uh
received
you know taken in had at least an id
they couldn't even answer that question
so we have no idea
senator we look forward to your
questions uh today you know getting that
second round hopefully uh you can
dig deeper maybe get them to admit one
mistake which they still haven't been
willing to like the letter like the
transcript of the phone call like the
transcript of the phone calls so many
things
that have still gone unanswered and with
him in person we look forward to
watching it but i want to get your take
you mentioned a series of other things
to include the border you mentioned 95
000 afghans there's that many people
still coming across our border a month
and it's something this administration
is seem to be content doing absolutely
nothing about we wanted to play a sound
bite of alison anderson she's a texas
land owner and the wife of a border
agent talking about this situation as
the administration wants to talk about
anything else she says the situation is
getting worse listen
my concerns are safety
um what we are saying is
we're overwhelmed uh with illegal
immigrants that are coming through our
property our neighborhood our community
we have a lot of moms with a lot of
little kids people are no longer letting
their kids out to play we found
footprints outside of our little girls
bedroom windows
i would say 100 is to buy an
administration's fault he needs to do
something it's it's hypocritical
to sit here and mandate vaccines against
citizens
at the same time the border is
completely wide open and there's
literally thousands of illegal
immigrants pouring over the border here
right now many that are infected with
either covid and or have been exposed to
covet or symptomatic to covet and
they're being released into our
communities
senator these are americans under siege
as you know and they feel like no one is
listening to them what what can at all
be done as this crisis almost goes
uncovered because there are so many
other crises created by this
administration
well this is a self-inflicted ruin wound
created by the president biden i mean he
is the root cause of this problem but
he's been aided and abetted by the
mainstream media and the social media
who are covering up for them
they've enabled all these disasters and
so you know the accountability has to
come in november of 2022 i wish it would
come sooner than that but it does not
look like this administration is
changing course whatsoever and of course
they're all concerned about kovid doing
a miserable job quite honestly uh
managing it
but they're completely unconcerned about
people with covert coming across the
border they're completely concerned
about all the people coming across the
border quite honestly they're
encouraging it so again this is a crisis
caused by president biden by his
policies and the accountability has got
to come in november 2022 where we have
to sweep democrats from power they have
enabled these crises they need to be
swept from power in 2022.
she said that they're
putting them underneath the bridge there
in the del rio sector and there are
about 2 000 of them down there and she
said then they put them on these buses
and they disperse them throughout our
country how do they decide where they're
going
they don't tell us they don't tell
states they don't tell cities you know
who's going to be coming into their
their jurisdictions
they aren't
acknowledging the depredations of the
human trafficking of the involuntary
servitude of the sex slaves
again they knew all of these things they
they know that is the the problem with
uncontrolled illegal immigration and yet
they are encouraging it again i i i
can't describe how frustrating it is
that the mainstream media won't cover
this it's amazing they'll be covering up
for afghanistan here they probably
already are they'll be calling president
biden profiling courage this is the
mainstream media's fault as well january
they went to fog about january 6th and
they put them under the bridge and if it
weren't for our drones we wouldn't have
had the footage of them
because they're out of view and you're
right no one else is covering it senator
thank you thank you
senator real quick are you going to run
again
i haven't made that decision but uh i'm
getting some pretty positive feedback
ooh okay maybe another six all right
thanks senator johnson appreciate it
have a good day you too